luke it is so nice to meet you congrats
on the show
uh first of all given you are from wales
were you familiar with the story
prior to signing on no i actually wasn't
um the when they reopened the case the
cold case it was uh 2011
and that was sort of at the beginning of
my film career and um
my feet sort of didn't touch the ground
for those first few years i
and i spent most of the time in other
countries so i sort of lost touch with a
lot of the
the headlines and the news that was that
was happening back in the united kingdom
so
um it was um when i got the script
in fact i got the script 18 months
before we actually shot it to the
beginning of 20
20 20. um so uh yeah
i was i was reading it in montreal and
uh i
firstly uh i had to sort of go and do my
own
research because i i i couldn't
believe the story to be honest with you
it was
it's such an extraordinary story and how
they actually
finally found the killer and all on the
investigative process
so i did my research and realized that
everything was completely 100
true and this terrible crime is unsolved
these unsolved murders had happened in
one of the most
beautiful picturesque parts of my home
country
um and uh yeah so it was um
it gripped me immediately i was i was
completely drawn into the story and
it felt like a story that deserved to be
told um
and uh you know when you do you play a
real character in a true life story
and then you take into account the
subject matter and how sensitive it is
because obviously there's a lot of
uh relatives of these victims are still
alive and
now you're telling them you have to be
respectful to them it was um
it was a huge responsibility but uh i
i'm very proud of what we've achieved
and um it's it's
had such a great reaction from everybody
it uh it's been
it's been really rewarding to read and
to see that
yeah it's it's definitely great work for
sure um
this series in particular i know it's
based on the book and it's
written by the detective that you play
did you get a chance to speak to the
detective
yeah i mean he steve wilkins who i
portray in in the drama
um he was with us during the prep uh we
did uh we had lots of
table meetings where uh it was either
just me and him or the director and him
and i and we would
sit and i he said you can ask me
anything which was
a real real gift because you know
there's
a lot of stuff you you often can't ask
but
uh you know in this position i i was i i
needed to know an awful lot about
so much stuff procedural stuff the way
you would handle being in an
interrogation room with a killer
trying to catch the killer out trying to
mean you know the just the way you
formulate
questions and how you present evidence
and how you
you have to uh keep this this
this suspect from shutting down and it
was really about the psychology of of
of this this this horrible man
but how the police and how this
detective and how steve wilkins managed
to do that
and then also you know steve is a family
guy he has a
he has a young son and he also has uh
you know and
he has a has a personal life as well as
a
a work life and it would it was
interesting hearing how he
how he juggled that and how difficult it
was and how you know
if anything it just gave me i already
had it but i
my respect and admiration for the police
force and these investigative teams
to you know the amount of work and hours
that they put into
you know um to finding killers
and taking these people off the streets
is it's extraordinary
why do you think people are so
fascinated by
true crime and are you a fan of that
genre
well i mean i can just go on my own
opinion and that's that
i'm it's always i mean a story is a good
story a good story is a good story but
when
it is a true life story i think there's
a human
there's a humanity to it that you can
immediately relate to because you go my
god these people
went through this this actually happened
um
i've always been um attracted to
biopics and i'm always fascinated with
them i i
when they're done well they you know you
it's like a it's
sort of like a history lesson but you
get to really see
the depth of that person's character and
the journey that they went on and this
was
one of those um i think and
it's done so well in the united kingdom
i mean it's it's
it's been extraordinary the um the
amount of people that have
that uh just just got the story and were
gripped from the first episode and have
been
uh it people were just you know bowed
over by it and it is because it's
it's an unbelievable story it how they
finally catch the killer
and the the tiny bits of evidence that
they find
during the years of investigating that
they did or reopening a cold case which
can never be
an enjoyable process because everything
that they are going to look at has
already been looked at in real depth
with a fine tooth comb and they didn't
they didn't catch the killer so the
amount of um
you know gumption that these people had
to reopen it because they had a hunch
that they
there was something there that hadn't
been found
i mean all that stuff just scripts me
and i was also you know when i was a kid
i was
fascinated with with forensic agency
it's coming off a long way
and watching um you know
the youth dna and and forensics
within the story really was uh was
something
really loved how does your approach
change you know as an actor when you're
doing a series like this versus
you know the hobbit or beauty and the
beast like how does your approach change
well you know a role is a role
you don't i don't think about anything
done prior to it and i don't think about
what i'm going to do after this role
it's just about this role you have to i
sort of
clear my mind my head of everything else
and i consume myself
with the world in which this person or
this character exists
um having access to the real person that
i play
was very very important and allowed me
to
build a much more layered
personality to this man and and and uh
and understand the professionality of of
him and how how he
how he did his job and and how he
managed everything his work life and his
personal life
and how he managed his team and it was
so it was easy in a way to just i i just
switch off from everything else i don't
think about anything else i mean
anytime you you remember that you've
played another character as if somebody
on the street while you're filming comes
up to you and asks you if you were
gaston and beauty and the beast or
dracula or you know um then you
then you're pulled out
um yeah i mean it is what it is and it's
uh
it's a nice thing but most of the time i
can just stay within the world
that i'm that i'm existing as the
character i think it's important because
there are so many distractions on set
there are so many distractions in life
um you really do have to immerse
yourself as much as possible
in the character and in the story and in
the other people that are in that story
with you the other actors and it's about
helping each other to stay
focused and and and know that we
were responsible for telling a a very
important story a very sad story and a
very
painful story for many people um you
know it wasn't that long ago and so
we were very aware that we were telling
a story that was uh
that sort of the the the relatives of
these victims
are still alive and so we had a huge
responsibility to be respectful and tell
the story
in the correct way and so that was uh
that was very important also
awesome and lastly i have to ask you
before you go
pinocchio coachman what
i'm really excited
what can you tell me i know i'm so
excited
what are you allowed to say i mean
what i i play the coachman which
you know that animation was made in 1940
which is an extraordinary long time ago
um and i remember when i when i was
offered it
i i spoke to my god children who are the
right age
for watching those all those animations
they they watch them all the time and
they were
when i said i was the coachman their
faces dropped
yeah they they were they were like
oh no he's horrible
um but you know it'll be very fun to
play
i mean it's a it's a very powerful story
pinocchio it has an awful lot of
messages
intertwined in in a very old story in an
old fairy tale
um and obviously to be in a movie even
if i'm not in a scene with
with him to just be in a film with tom
hanks is a
is a lovely bucket list moment i don't
even know whether i'll meet him but
uh just to share a screen with him would
be a very nice thing
and um i'm very excited i mean i've
always been very proud of my time
uh with with the disney family and i
i've loved every second of
bringing gaston to life and now i'm
going to be part of another
great big uh you know live-action remake
which they do so well
and so i'm i'm i'm itching to get back
from australia to start preparing for
for the role
you